[Music]
they say history repeats itself I'm a
big believer in this theory which is why
I try to spend more time on the show
talking about big ideas and political
philosophies rather than day-to-day
political rumblings most of our
political debates and media coverage has
devolved into catchy sound bites and
zingers usually staged around some sort
of publicity stunt instead of true
substantive debate even protesting these
days seems to be more about screaming
and hashtagging than making a coherent
argument just think back to the election
itself did the candidates in the media
spend more time on the issues or more
time on the circus I think the answer is
pretty obvious understanding political
philosophies helps to guide us through
the endless noise that comes out of our
political machine this is why I've tried
to talk about issues like gay marriage
in a context which shows you can be
liberal and for gay marriage because you
want gay people to be treated equally
under the law or you can be libertarian
in for gay marriage because you don't
want the government involved in a
contract between two consenting adults
if you understand the philosophic
underpinnings of liberalism and
libertarianism in this case it can bring
you to the exact same conclusion without
understanding political philosophy your
thoughts on any day-to-day issue will be
guided more by your feelings than by
facts we see plenty of feelings over
facts in our public discourse these days
and it's partly why we're so divided as
a nation by the way that isn't to say
that feelings don't matter at all
because we are humans and of course they
do but the way we're governed has to be
based on what is empirically true not
just what makes us feel good beyond just
knowing political philosophies knowing
history is an incredibly important part
of having a well-rounded understanding
of how the world works think of how many
people you talk to who claim to know
everything about what tax system is
right or what foreign policy is best
next time ask them something like so
tell me the reasons that the flat tax is
wrong or remind me of the history of the
Middle East during the Ottoman Empire
everyone on television seems to have the
need to pretend they know everything
about everything these are the very
people you have to watch out for the
moat
if history does repeat itself I'm not
exactly sure what its repeating right
now and no I don't think we're repeating
Nazi Germany even though it's very
trendy to say that these days we truly
are at a unique crossroads in American
politics which is why I can't directly
compare it to any other time it's not
just that America has two diametrically
opposed political parties that are
caught between the left and the right
now with Donald Trump in the White House
we have a presidential wild card who has
turned political alignments on their
head for example Democrats are now
suddenly suddenly arguing for states
rights because they don't like all the
federal power Trump has with his series
of executive orders this political chaos
is also pushing massive amounts of
people sick of the extremes on both
sides into some sort of amorphous middle
there doesn't seem to be a political
leader for this new center nor anyone in
the mainstream talking about it yet but
mark my words it's here the key to this
new centers success will be who sees it
first and who turns it into a political
movement whether that means a new party
or reforming one of the two existing
major parties or signing us all together
well that remains to be seen on top of
this new political alignment we also
have access to information like never
before as I talk about all the time we
all walk around with the world in our
pocket right now you can connect with
someone across the globe just as easily
as with someone across the street the
genius and power of the Internet's
ability to change our physical world
can't be overstated
this connectivity has started
revolutions in the Middle East and shine
light on the inner workings of our
government via WikiLeaks but at the same
time so much of the information is not
just noise alone but noise intended to
deflect confuse and upset you made by
people who want to profit off you or
outright control you of course if our
mainstream media had done their job for
the past eight years which is to be the
Guardian of truth in our society then
maybe the importance of the internet
wouldn't be so vital to our functioning
democracy in 2017 unfortunately cable
and network news dropped the ball at
almost every corner and here
are they cozy to the power instead of
keeping it in check they colluded with
the people they were supposed to keep
watch over and they partied with the
very politicians that they were supposed
to be reporting on now suddenly the
mainstream media is trying to get its
mojo back by being hard on Trump but I
would argue that it's basically too late
to do that actually it's kind of sad
seeing them flail around knowing that
less and less people are paying
attention to them even right now there's
talk that they are going to cancel the
White House Correspondents Dinner
because so many in the media dislike
Trump think how actually insane that is
when they like the president they can
party with them and drink with them now
that they don't well the jig is up maybe
we needed them to guard the guy they
liked as much as the guy that they don't
like at the same time we more and more
cater the news to ourselves we don't
listen to pundits we don't like we
impugn the motives of anyone we disagree
with and we block friends and family who
dare have different opinions than us all
of this is exactly why we need to know
history and philosophy more now than
ever we need to understand where we came
from so we can know where we're going we
need to know why the founding fathers
wrote the Constitution the way they did
we need to understand why they yearn for
freedom and liberty in a way that seems
almost archaic to us now
but it's possibly the most important
lesson we could learn this year with all
this in mind I can't think of a better
guest for this week as we continue our
partnership with the fine folks over at
learn Liberty Dan Carlin is a radio and
TV personality who hosts two incredibly
successful podcasts common sense and
hard core history as a self-described
political Martian Dan uses thought
experiments to try to make some sense of
the modern world on his podcast hardcore
history he hosts long well-thought-out
presentations of historical events set
to the backdrop of how we might view
these events through a current-day lens
while he isn't technically a historian
he's proven himself to be incredibly
adept at storytelling history in a way
that offered some modern-day answers to
historical events if history repeats
itself then let's make the next repeat a
little more enlightened and perhaps a
little less painful than the last time
around
[Music]
you
you